фінансова Імперія так називали бізнес
Євгена пригожина
журналісти-розслідувачі деякий час тому
виявили кілька сотень компанії
пов'язаних з його ім'ям але ніхто так і
не дізнався де його бізнес починається А
де закінчується
[музика]
соляр їх там кілька десятків компанії а
може і сотень які постачали за
держконтрактами їжу до московських шкіл
та дитячих садків це гігантський ринок і
він там був майже монополістом
детские сады але найвідоміші
підприємства пригожина це пвк Вагнер
найманці воювали у війні Росії проти
України а також були присутній в Сирії
судані та центрального африканській
Республіці у цих країнах бізнес інтереси
пригожина тісно перепліталися з
політикою у Сирії вони намагалися
освоїти нафту та газ у судані добували
золото у цар золото та алмази це не
означає що ця гілка була самоокупною але
вони намагалися хоч щось зробити на тому
що вони роблять ми по витоку з
бухгалтерії бачили що це такий
плановозбитковий захід який робиться щоб
у пригожина були якісь політичні бали
мовляв ми просуваємо інтереси Росії це
було важливо мабуть для Кремля для
Путіна
для Путіна здавалося такі розгалужені
бізнес-активи колишнього кремлівського
кухаря мають становити інтереси і після
його загибелі але поки що на них ніхто
не претендує експерти вважають причиною
те що майже весь бізнес прихоже на
будувався на особистих зв’язках
зрозуміло що фізично нікуди не
подінеться десь кудись їх спробують
перенаправити віддати іншим командирам
хтось просто перейде в аналогічні
підприємства хтось додому поїде але все
так само як федеральне агентство новин
було було клас все немає
агентство головне питання що буде з пвк
Вагнер яка після спроби заколоту в Росії
передислокувалася до Білорусі Олександр
Лукашенко повідомив що ця група
залишиться на території Білорусі але
водночас стало відомо про те що
наметовий табір у могильовській області
почали демонтувати
ядро хтось поїхав у відпустку Хтось
взагалі вирішив жити осторонь але
телефони адреси паролі явки у цьому
штабі у цьому ядрі відомі протягом
кількох днів усі будуть тут до 10 тисяч
людей в чечені нескольких дней все
будуть здесь до 10 000 человек
хоча за словами Лукашенко Він не знає
хто може стояти за збиттям літака
прихожана він упевнений що Володимир
Путін до цього не причетний
робота якщо вже на те пішло Це не схоже
на Путіна але щоб там не трапилося хоч
би як там трапилося все одно це звалять
на Путіна
Лукашенко також висловився і про
гарантії безпеки які він нібито давав
пригожину після невдалого заколоту вах
на вівців в Росії
я її не маю забезпечувати безпеку
пригожина це по-перше по-друге ніколи
про це розмова в такому ключі знайшла
Він просто хоче показати що він тут не
задіяний тобто він виконав свою частину
контракту і він знову ж таки вигородив
Путіна і себе а далі хоче щоб йому дали
спокій
британський експерт Майк Мартін вважа що
для пвк Вагнер велику роль відігравала
особистість самогоївке на пригожина тому
головне питання зараз чи зможе
організація зберегти свою цілісність
Я думаю що якби все склалося так як
хочеться Путіну то пвк вахнер було б
розділено деякі її частини дістануться
армії деякі Можливо будуть в Африці
Таким чином у Путіна буде кілька
об'єднань з якими він матиме справу
при цьому хоч пвк Вагнер тепер
зареєстровано у Білорусі керувати нею
будуть з Москви вважають експерти
машинка
сам заявив що за все платить Москва
тобто за все платить Хтось ще за все за
останній аркуш паперу за чайник для
намету все це оплачується іншою стороною
тому я думаю що Звісно Лукашенко у цій
ситуації у всій цій ситуації самого
початку був весільним генералом
присутність вагнерівців на території
Білорусі позначається на відносинах із
сусідніми країнами Польща і Литва не
виключають повного закриття кордонів але
за словами Григорія нижнікова якогось
особливого сенсу у присутності пвк на
території Білорусі немає
для чого її використати для залякування
Польщі це може зайнятись і білоруська
армія білоруські прикордонники
відповідно швидше за все ми можемо
говорити про те що до кінця року їх
просто відправлять туди де вони
потрібніший до Африки припустимо до
України ми не знаємо неймовірніше і туди
і туди
і туди і туди